[Music]
next question
next question this one comes from
gliazza amoroso
she says hello i followed pastor's skeet
question and answer videos i have a
question
genesis chapter 1 says god spoke and
everything created
except man and woman genesis 2 verse 19
and out of the ground god
the lord god formed every beast of the
field and every fowl of the air
and brought them unto adam to see what
he would call them and whatsoever adam
called every crete every living creature
that was the name thereof
this verse stays out of the ground god
formed every beast of the field i'm
confused animals or beasts were
i guess she says animals or beasts were
created by what i guess she wants to
know did god just speak and they came to
be or did god you know physically go on
the ground and formed animals out of the
dust of the earth
now to explain that i may need another
hour which we certainly do
there is a sermon i preach called
hands-free operation
it is somewhere on youtube uh someone
who's curious you may try to find that
sermon but i dealt exactly with this
issue
now i have
if you read psalm 138 for stu
it says
he has magnified his word above all his
name the word of god has priority above
everything else the righteousness of god
is the fact that god is always faithful
to his word
and that's the way we ought to be
because god's word is right he has
magnified his word
above all his name psalm 138 verse 2.
the word of god cannot be minimized at
all because that is what we are to live
by
man shall not live by bread alone but by
every word now
having said that genesis 1 3 verse 1 in
the beginning god created the heaven and
the earth
the question is how did he do that
psalm 33 verse 6 by the word of the lord
where the heavens made and all the hosts
of them by the breath of his mouth
hebrews 11 3 through 5th we understand
that the worlds were formed of frame by
the word of god it is the word of god
now how were angels made psalm 148
verses 1 2 and 3 praise you the lord
praise the lord from the heavens praise
him in the heights praising him all his
angels praising him all his host verse 5
let them praise the name of the lord for
he commanded and they were created
patriots and prophets phase 38 paragraph
three christ was the son of god he had
been one with him before the angels were
called into existence
god created angels by simply speaking
and this is what we learned in psalm 148
verse 5. he simply spoke and angels came
now if you look at genesis chapter 1
for every day of creation
we have the word let
let there be light
let there be a firmament let the waters
under the heavens
let the earth bring forth grass
let there be light in the firmament let
the waters let the waters bring forth
abundantly for day five efficiency let
the earth bring forth living creatures
let us make man in our image we have let
for every day of creation and for
everything of creation it seems the
point that everything created was
created by the word of god now i've
searched the bible and wise writings i
need to continue doing that to look for
a clear statement which says
god stood down
scooped up dirt with his hand and
laboriously formed adam and eve and
consequently every animal i have not yet
found that sometimes people point to the
expression the hand the hand of the
bible frequently bends the exercise of
authority you understand so when the
bible says lest he put forth his hand
and take and eat ultimately of life when
adam consumed the forbidden fruit he did
not put forth his hand to the tree i
mean he brought it to him he didn't have
to put forth his hand at all in other
words lest he exercise his will to go
eat that fruit the hand of god
frequently made the exercise of god's
sovereign will that no one can turn back
he brought out the israelites with a
stretched out arm and a mighty hand
simply means the exercise of his power
now
when i consider thy heavens the works of
life fingers the moon and the stars
which thou has now what do you mean the
words of thy fingers is simply the
exercise of god's power now listen to
this quotation this is let me pray again
father please give me simple language in
the name of jesus i appeal to you amen
listen to ellen white in the ministry of
healing page 414 paragraph five the
minister of healing page 414 paragraph
five listen very carefully
everything
material or spiritual
stood up
before the lord god the lord jehovah at
his voice and were created for his own
purpose now listen again
everything material
or spiritual
stood up before the lord jehovah at his
voice
and were created for his own purpose he
goes on to say the heavens and all the
hosts of them the earth and all things
therein came into existence by the
breath of his mouth
now in the same book we got page 415 now
paragraph one the ministry of healing
page 415 paragraph one i will quote the
quotation but i'll leave out two words
here's the quotation
through christ
a personal god created man and endowed
him with intelligence and power let me
say it again through christ and that's
very true ephesians 3 9 hebrews 1 2 the
father created through christ christ was
the agent of creation he did it but for
the father now through christ
a personal god created man and endowed
him with intelligence and power
keep those words in your mind through
christ a personal god created man now
let me give you the whole quotation
through christ the word
a personal god created man and endowed
with intelligence and power now why
would she serve through christ the word
through christ the word a personal god
created man and endowed with what i'm
trying to get to consider this is not a
doctrine i'm trying to spread i just
want you to consider that all of
creation was by the word of god there's
another reason well let me go to the
book of uh let's go to john the
resurrection of lazarus
when jesus says take me away the stone
they said lord by this time he stinketh
i think that's a reef in verse 39
he thinketh
and
so jesus understood what martha was
saying he has begun to be comfort in
other words what you have back behind
that stone is there in a certain sense
he's going back to dirt a dead person is
not effectively dust because the life is
gone you see and the lord god formed
that of the dust of the ground breathed
into his nostrils the breath of life man
became a living soul remove the breath
all you have is dust nice dust now jesus
stood outside of the tomb of the cave
and he said lazarus come forth he never
touched him
he spoke and thus came to life now let's
look at the most severe example
first corinthians 4 16 so the lord
himself shall descend from heaven with a
shout with the voice of the archangel
with the trump of god and the dead in
christ shall rise first now wait a
minute wait a minute the dead in christ
that goes all the way back to abel
abel is the first thing to die as far as
we know recorded in scripture if anyone
is dust is able
he's been dead before everybody else
this man is dust in the dustiest sense
of the word
jesus will stand somewhere in heaven are
you following me he doesn't touch the
earth and he speaks and abel is formed
as a human being
he is formed as a human being along with
every other righteous person who saw
corruption meaning a decay of the body
he does not use his hands
he just speaks
now there's another principle to keep in
mind the bible teaches the power that
creates is the power that maintains it
let me say that again the power that
creates you is the same power that
sustains you you can't have one power
creating at a different power sustaining
that does not work biblically second
peter chapter three read from verse five
and seven
for this they willingly are ignorant of
that by the word of god the heavens were
evolved and the earth standing out of
the water and in the water escape the
sun but the heaven and the earth which
are now by that same word are kept in
store in other words the same creative
word mentioned in verse 5 is the word
that preserves in for seven let me say
it again a biblical principle what
creates is what preserves and so we read
in hebrews chapter one from verse one to
three god who at sundry times and in
diverse manners speak in time past unto
the fathers by the prophets that in
these last days spoken unto us by his
son whom he hath appointed heir of all
things by whom also he made the world
first three who being the brightness of
his glory and the express image of his
person and upholding all things by the
word of his power the word of his power
that holds is the word of his power that
created
now i realize it's very difficult to
accept this because we've grown up
seeing god very nicely kneeling down in
the dirt and scooping up there that's
what we've seen but i do not yet see
from the bible where that is taught or
from the writings of white
now as i said i'm not trying to promote
a doctrine i'm simply asking you just
consider
is there any evidence from scripture and
elderly to suggest
that all this creation was done by the
word of god
if you say
that creationist human beings were done
by the hand the literal hand of god then
you've got to say it is by that same
literal hand that we're sustained but
the bible says no we're sustained by the
word of god therefore we must have been
created by the word of god you see and
so the question is
consider this as well if you read
genesis 2 verse 7 and the lord god
formed man of the dust of the ground you
read genesis 2 19 and out of the ground
the lord god from the every beast of the
earth you also have to say if god stood
and formed man with his hand he also
stood and formed every land animal every
bird every fish because they will all go
back to dust when they die
and no one believes it
and so the formation of man
what i see in the bible and alone why is
that it is the word of god and to deny
the word of god the power to create
physically is to deny the word of god
the power to create spiritually because
we know from first second peter chapter
1 verse 20 of first peter 1 23 being
born again not of corruptable seed but
of incorruptible by the word of god now
being born again that is spiritual
creation it is done by the word of god
james 1 18 of his own will begetting us
with the word of truth
spiritual creation
is uh is parallel with physical creation
in physical creation god created out of
nothing in spiritual creation we can't
bring raw materials to god and say begin
with this we have nothing to offer god
he makes us out of nothing and so what i
am seeing in the scripture of white is
that creation all six days was done by
the word of god when you understand that
you more clearly understand the
importance of the word for sustaining
you
the important because that is what made
you and it's a lot of christians have no
time for the bible they do not
understand the word of god made them
physically it is the word of god that
makes them spiritually and sustains them
then they begin to see it is the word so
jesus says man shall not live by bread
alone but by every word and the person
who said that was the one who created in
genesis 1. and so i offer that to you
for your consideration
if you find an elevated quotation that
says god use his hands and bow down and
stoop down and well send it to me or
verse that says that send it to me
that was long and tiring but i hope you
got something from it
okay
enough of this
yes we did we did the word of god oh my
god powerful the word god is powerful it
creates it sustains it redeems there's
another quotation my good sister i think
it is desirable it is page 320 paragraph
two there's our videos speak 320
paragraph two i believe it is crack down
white is commenting on the resurrection
of the widow's son the word of name luke
chapter seven and christ's sort of
funeral procession he touched the coffin
the guy uh he said young man i see until
they arise otherwise says as the word of
god which bid the first man live
give life to the to the to the widow's
son the youth of name now
as the word of god
which made the first man live
what's he saying it is by the word of
god adam came into existence
it gives us life today
saw the word you know
uh young man i see under the arise the
same word
and that word gives life to us
spiritually when the bible says in
ephesians 4 15 awake thou that sleepless
and arise from the dead that's the word
when you accept that word you come to
life spiritually because it has as much
power as let there be light or let it be
affirmative and so
you cannot have a teaching that
minimizes the word of god
but again i'm not promoting the doctrine
i'm simply saying consider what i've
said that's all i'm saying consider
amen amen
this is why we have to personalize the
promises of god friends
your name in those bible verses when
you're doing promises because god's word
has power to change our situations and
bring things to past that otherwise
would not because god's word cannot fail
god's way too